سواء كان ذلك تركيبًا فنيًا معاصرًا
أو منحوتة مستوحاة من فن اللافتات الإسلامية ،
فلديه القدرة على إعادة تعريف المدينة
وتجربتها الحضرية فقط أخبرني
عن ترميم هذه المباني القديمة
لأنها رائعة للغاية لأنها
المرأة في مركز كل
هذا  شاكر حور القاسمي ، عاصفة هادئة
، وضعت إمارة الشارقة النائمة
على خريطة الفن على مستوى العالم ، مما ساعد على
جعلها واحدة من أكثر الأصوات تأثيراً
في مجالها ، كما أن الكثير من
المتاحف العالمية تأتي إلى
بينالينا ، لذا إذا كان عليك أن تأخذ الحديث
سترى مارون ريشما الذي يعمل ،
سترى أعمال شريف روكتس كلها من
البينالي الماضي. تم إدراج أعمال 9mo hyneman الآن في
القائمة المختصرة لجائزة تيرنر
، الحدث الرئيسي للمؤسسة ، يعد تشارجر
بينالي من بين
أكبر التجمعات الفنية المعاصرة في الشرق الأوسط مع
الإضافة السابقة  جذب 200000
زائر والتجول في أماكن بعيدة
مثل السنغال ، ومن المعروف أنني أحب
كل مدينة أذهب إليها
وأحب كل مدينة  أذهب إلى جزء آخر من
الشارقة ، وقد أخذها شغف العائلة المالكة الإماراتية
بالفنون في جميع أنحاء
العالم لتكوين عقلية دولية ،
وهذا ما تسبب في بعض
الاحتكاك مع الحرس القديم بعد أن
تولت مقاليد البينالي مرة أخرى
في  في أوائل العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين ، استخدموا
أسلوب جناح البندقية القديم مع
تمثيل البلد ، وقلت مع عدم وجود أي
شخص من بلد واحد بعد الآن ،
لا يمكنك تصنيف الأشخاص بهذه الطريقة ، لذلك
نحتاج إلى تغيير هذا ، لذلك كنت أقوم بإجراء
الكثير من التغييرات و  كان باقي أعضاء
اللجنة فنانين بشكل أساسي قرروا
قبل ستة أشهر من الافتتاح
أنهم استقالوا وأعمل 20 ساعة في اليوم
سبعة أيام في الأسبوع كنا فريقًا صغيرًا
كنت أقوم بتنظيف الأرضية
صباح الافتتاح كنت ألصق
الملصقات.  كانت معلقة وحصلت على بعض
الإطلالات من بعض الأشخاص مثلك ،
فأنت لست ابنة الحاكم
وتكنس الأرض ، لكن شاحن
مؤسسة الفن يمتد إلى ما بعد
البينالي الذي يستضيف حوالي 10 معارض في كل مكان.
ch year وعرض مؤخرًا
أعمال الفنان البريطاني فرانك بولاند
الذي صنع اسمًا لنفسه في الستينيات
، يُطلق على المعرض اسم mappa Mundi ، لذا
فهو يبحث في خرائطه وهجرته
ويتحدث أيضًا عن تجارة الرقيق
في نفس الوقت الذي رحل فيه من  من غيانا إلى
لندن إلى الولايات المتحدة ،
هذه مساحة رائعة لم يكن
لدينا أي فنان قلناها آسف لأنك
لا تستطيع إظهار هذا لأنك تعلم أنه
جنسي أو إباحي ، فنحن مهتمون أكثر
بالسياسة بالتشكيك في الأشياء التي يقومون بها  يحدث من
حولنا شغف يحدد إلى حد كبير
هذه القوة الملكية في عالم الفن
والذي تريد مشاركته مع
الآخرين